era esperado el boicot diplomático de
eeuu a los juegos olímpicos de pequeño y
era esperada también la respuesta de
china está llegado desde todos los
frentes del ministerio exteriores las
embajadas y la prensa el mensaje es el
mismo la medida eeuu es sólo un acto
pretencioso y teatral porque de todas
formas china no había invitado a sus
políticos pero también es una violación
flagrante de la neutralidad política en
el deporte y una manipulación de los
hechos porque opina china que eeuu
apunta las sus acusaciones de crímenes
contra la humanidad en mentiras y
rumores el ministerio de exteriores ha
anunciado medidas contundentes de
castigo que no ha aclarado y sugerido
que este boicot va a entorpecer la
colaboración entre ambos países es poco
probable que el conflicto termina aquí
porque nueva zelanda ha anunciado
también que no enviara a sus políticos a
los juegos y canadá australia y el reino
unido- se lo están planteando son los
países que acostumbran a alinearse a
eeuu en su política de confrontación con
china